Well, I was thrilled that "Lincoln" was a success...
...and as I was thinking about what to do next,...
...in the middle of the night, I woke up and it hit me.
Obama.
Picking the right actor to play Obama, that was the challenge.
I mean, who is Obama really?
We don't know.
So I needed someone who can dive in and really become Barack Obama.
And as it turns out, the answer was right in front of me all along.
Daniel Day-Lewis.
He becomes his characters.
Hawkeye from "Last of the Mohicans" and Bill the Butcher from "Gangs of New York"...
...and Abraham Lincoln in "Lincoln."
And you know what?
He nailed it.
Was it hard playing Obama?
I'll be honest, yeah, it was.
This accent took a while.
Hello, Ohio!
I love you back.
Look.
Let me be clear about this.
The cosmestics were challenging.
You wouldn't believe how long it takes to put these ears on in the morning.
I don't know how he walks around with these things.
Once we had Daniel to play Obama, we had to cast the rest of his team.
And I think we've got some pretty terrific performances.
Working with a legend like Daniel is intimidating.
But he makes everyone better.
Without him, I never could have played Joe Biden, literally.
Hi, I'm Joe Biden.